[Music]
this Sunday's ACM Awards and we're with
the Stars gearing up for country music's
biggest night the seating cards are in
place nominee Blake is sitting on the
aisle
so his country fan Ashton Kutcher
rehearsals are underway and reigning
queen of country Reba McEntire is ready
to host for the 15th time the last time
I hosted was with Blake Shelton I really
enjoy hosting it's very exciting a love
live television also on the bill
Entertainer of the Year nominee Jason
Aldean he'll be back performing in Vegas
for the first time since the devastating
mass shooting during his performance at
the route 91 Harvest Festival in October
imagine for you there's got to be a lot
of mixed emotions with going back to
Vegas just a little bit of a weird
feeling but and excited that it's you
know that I'm going out there with the
country music family I think it's kind
of a perfect way to really go back and
and do it for the first time eg online
social AC was with Jason at his
iHeartRadio album release party last
night celebrating his new record rear
view town
Jason has had a lot of big life changes
this past year including the birth of
his son
Memphis how much are you traveling with
the baby we got him a crib on the bus
he's ready to rock points the tour
starts so he's ready to go so great the
53rd annual ACM Awards airs live Sunday
at 8:00 on CBS
[Music]
[Applause]